the regular basic functions we also
got this log function in there so that
we could get tan
we've done all of our reciprocal
functions okay so now i want to think
about
the basic ones but when you square them
okay
so uh can i fit over here
yeah maybe okay let's try so i'm up to
eight
okay now if i want to integrate for
instance sine squared x
sine squared x what am i going to what
what will help me
to integrate how am i going to change
the shape of sine squared in order to
fit it into something that i had already
know how to degrade what am i going to
use
i'm going to use double angle yeah okay
so maybe just in another color
you can note down let's see how much ink
i have left in this okay
cos 2x okay you can write this in two
different ways yeah
so i wanted to do sine squared first so
instead of writing it as cos squared
minus sine squared
i'll write it as 1 minus sine squared
minus sine squared
is that okay so if i want sine squared
on its own
you take the one over
that's and now i divide by
negative two okay so that's going to
switch the order here and put a half out
the front
sign squared x is
a half one minus
all right so therefore
so that was my that's my preliminary
result much like these
preliminary results which lead to this
so if i integrate both sides with
respect to x
the integral of sine squared x dx
is equal to i'm going to leave that half
out the front
the x okay so the one
that's just going to turn into x what's
this 10 into careful
reverse chain rule what's it going to
turn into
it's it's going to have come from a sign
to x right but because you've got your
two there that's going to multiply at
the front when you do chain rule if we
were
considering in reverse so therefore you
get half out the front
1 turns into an x and this will turn
into negative
half sine 2x
plus your constant okay so if you can
think you know just to check
if you were to differentiate this back
the two come out the front and you'd
cancel out so that's why the coefficient
is just one so x on two
um oh yeah that's okay
a quarter scientific okay
all right therefore uh yeah
if i were to do cos squared um i can
take advantage of the same identity
right except instead of saying cos 2x is
equal to
this which is in terms of all the signs
what difference does it make when i put
it in terms of clauses
so i'm going to get 2 cos squared x
minus 1. yeah
so now when i'm integrating um cos
squared x instead
okay the eventual result i think when
you get to this point you'll have a plus
here instead of a minus
so i'll be integrating sorry half out
the front 1
plus cos 2x
with respect to x so because this is so
similar it's just a change of sign
i'm going to go straight to this line
but it's a plus
okay yep all right okay so far
okay this i welcome thinking about
things all right last one uh sine
squared cos squared
tan squared now um before i write down
tan squared
how we what are we going to do what are
we going to how we're going to change it
it's still it still starts from a
similar identity but it's not it's not
this one
which one should we use
good so just to rewind if you're not too
good with remembering your
arm i was never good at remembering the
sec squared and tan squared one
just start back at this one let's
generally agree that this one's not too
hard to remember
and to get from here to the tan and sec
one
you divide everything through by cos
squared right
because you see that's going to turn
that into one
right it's going to turn this into tan
squared
and it turns this into
sec squared right so 1
tan squared sec squared what i really
want is just tan squared
so i'll move this one over to the other
side
okay all right so therefore
when i'm integrating sec squared sorry
when i'm integrating tan squared
what i'll end up with is
sec squared minus one
okay and this brings us back to our one
over here which is 6 squared goes back
to regular tan
so x
plus your constant all right now we'll
get to the inverse trig ones a bit later
on
um but the sheet i give you i'm going to
give you in a second that's
plenty to get started just in case you
couldn't remember it um
i hope it helps you to see where they
come from i had a lot of trouble even
though they're like a lot of them are on
the standard integral sheet
still using them properly i would get
things mixed up because so many of them
are so similar to each other
okay so if you're getting mixed up or
confused with any of them
just come back to the results you know
right and then get the results you need
from those okay